Texas wants its gold back from New York
the Lone Star State has 650 million
dollars of the gold bar sitting in a
vault in midtown Manhattan but now they
want to bring it back to Texas so
joining us now with more from Austin is
Bloomberg News reporter Lauren edirol
Lauren give us the background here what
is going on well
so essentially Texas owns 650 million
dollars worth of gold the University of
Texas Investment Management Company
started buying gold bars a few years ago
after the Great Recession and they
stored in New York and in Texas there's
a there's a great interest in bringing
it back right now that's largely because
the state is concerned that there's
there's sort of a fever here right now
where people want to make sure that the
federal government doesn't have their
hands all over anything Texas and that
now involves the gold Laura and I have
heard reports that Texas intelligence
got word that federal troops were moving
forces in inside the state and then the
governor mobilized local militia as a
precaution what the hell is going on
there well this is sort of spun out of
control a little bit there's a word came
out that there's a federal military US
military exercise it's gonna be taking
place across the u.s. called Jade helm
this this happened a couple of months
ago word came out and in Texas sort of
again playing to this rising sentiment
in the state that the federal government
is out to get them he sort of said you
know look we're gonna we're gonna deploy
some of our state forces or at least
keep them on call to keep an eye on the
federal government so a lot of it is
politics that's going on here that's
basically what's happening with the goal
to but Greg Abbott the governor of Texas
is essentially playing a game of
brinksmanship with the US federal
government can that be real well I think
that maybe it's like I said it's gone a
little bit too far I mean the governor
has said
he the state of Texas has been clear
that they're not trying to take on the
feds really I think it's just more
sending the message that look people
here in Texas we don't where we know
we're watching you we're keeping our eye
we're looking out for our state so I
don't think there's actually going to be
a war that's gonna break out between the
US government and Texans but hey it's
been done in the past right right so
this is a lot of posturing and obviously
shows a deep deep mistrust of the
federal government Lauren what's
interesting here is the golden question
is not even the property of the state
itself it belongs to the University of
Texas their endowment specifically UT
actually has the second biggest
endowment according to Bloomberg
rankings at just over twenty five
billion dollars
what does UT think of all this well I
think they're sort of they haven't been
that involved in it I mean look they
they bought the gold a few years ago for
their own investment reasons they have
the reasons for doing that and the CEO
of u Temko told me hey if we still have
gold if it's if it's part of the conex
system if the vault is part of the Comex
system if this is something that
actually happens and the fees are lower
than what we're paying in new york hey
why not we'll take one for the home team
bring it on back
that makes sense I mean why why pay to
hold it way up here in Yankee territory
when you could just put it in the Alamo
yourselves what what are you gonna
actually do with it what is that just
gonna actually do with it when they get
it back I mean that's a really good
question and there's so many of these
little details that of course the devil
is in the details people so the
Comptroller needs to work out what's
actually gonna happen but there is it
there is an idea that eventually this
vault in this depository could end up
working like a gold back bank where
people citizens government entities
school districts would be able to make
transactions gold back transactions
based on this depository
so it's yet to be seen but there are
some designs in the makings there's
always designs in the making in Texas I
suspect all right Laura now thank you so
much for joining us from Austin Texas